welcome to episode 79 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode i had kelly brogan on
this was one of my favorite podcasts
kelly is sharp she's a psychiatrist now
a holistic psychiatrist
author of the new york times bestselling
book a mind of your own
own yourself the children's book a time
for reign and co-editor
of the landmark textbook integrative
therapies for depression
if you're suffering from depression or
mental illness or relationship problems
or emotional problems
this episode is really worth watching
and taking seriously
she's the founder of the online healing
program vital mind reset
and the membership community vital life
project she completed her psychiatric
training and fellowship
at nyu medical center after graduating
from cornell university
medical college and has a bachelor of
science from mit
in systems neuroscience she specializes
in a root cause
resolution approach to psychiatric
syndromes and symptoms
she's a powerhouse we spoke about
psychiatry in conventional western
medicine
and alternative medicine super
alternative
ssris messed me up they helped me
initially
then ruined my life for a number of
years after i stopped taking them so
this is a topic
very close to my heart if you enjoy
these episodes please hit subscribe
this episode is brought to you by
superspeciosa a kratom company
kratom is a herb related to the coffee
plant the leaves or
extracts from the leaves have been used
as a stimulant and a sedative
it works on opiate receptors in the
brain so it's been used to treat chronic
pain
digestive ailments and aid in withdrawal
from opiate dependence
if you tried cbd and you felt like it
isn't quite what you're looking for or
even if you like cbd but you also want
to try something else
kratom might be for you there have also
been reports of kratom abuse
but whenever you try anything don't be
stupid don't drink 12 cups of coffee a
day or you'll get withdrawal
do your research and decide drugs are
drugs i myself occasionally like kratom
and think it can be beneficial if used
properly
i've used it as a substitute for coffee
coffee doesn't make me feel good
or is an overall calming tea some people
use it to manage stress and to help them
relax
i know how hard this year has been and
is on people and something like kratom
tea
is safer in my opinion than a
pharmaceutical it's very effective
superspeciosa has different strains some
help you relax some give you energy
whatever you're looking for they have
you covered this kratom is reliable
third
lab tested and approved under the
american kratom association's quality
standards program
only natural kratom no other ingredients
visit
getsuperleaf.com mp to buy small
servings or in bulk
either way you'll be saving a lot of
money to get guaranteed high quality
kratom
so if you want to try kratom you can get
20 off by going to get
super leaf dot com mp enter code mp for
off thanks super speciosa for the
sponsorship
enjoy the episode
[Music]
dr kelly brogan welcome to my podcast
it's an honor
it's an honor for me i'm so excited to
talk to you i've known about you for a
while but
it's cool getting you on the podcast so
thank you i'm excited yes thank you
can we start off by you giving a brief
background about
who you are and what it is you do yeah i
guess so the most
relevant and interesting uh detail about
my
sort of resume so to speak is that i
have
had many many a rebirth right so i'm
probably on like my
eighth personality in this lifetime and
i was very very much uh kind of died in
the wool
believer in what i now refer to as the
church of scientism
but what was previously referred to in
my life as conventional medicine
and i became interested in becoming a
allopathic doctor when i was at mit
for undergrad and i was working a
suicide hotline actually called
nightline and suicide is a completed
suicide actually is a big issue
at mit probably still is this was some
time ago obviously but
i became really inspired and
convinced that we had cracked the code
of
human behavior and human suffering and
that psychiatry and associated
medications held the answer and so we
just needed to
connect those who are suffering to the
system that would help them
and i was supervised by this
grandfatherly
psychiatrist and i thought wow i really
want to
do good in the world through this field
and so i went to medical school you know
with that
intent and i specialized in
a burgeoning field at the time called
reproductive psychiatry which is the
believe it or not medicating with
psychotropics of pregnant and
breastfeeding
women i was one of the first 300 in the
world
as as you know what ultimately was
emerging at the time was the fact that
one in four women were on
psychotropic medications going into
pregnancies or considering pregnancy or
unexpectedly you know pregnant and we
didn't have the data
to help them make any sort of informed
decision and so there were a group of
dedicated uh psychiatrists who
were really focusing mostly on what's
called registry data which is the
passive collection
of outcomes by the pharmaceutical
companies themselves
to kind of inform whether or not there
are any major red flags or major
signals of harm and so i spent some time
you know
trying to help women navigate whether to
continue medication
start them discontinue them but the only
so-called alternative
was just not taking your meds right
there wasn't this concept that there's
anything else to do
with symptoms other than you know
psychotherapy medication or just
kind of like white knuckle it and
so it really wasn't until i was uh
pregnant myself postpartum
and diagnosed with my first health
condition and prior to that i had been
very kind of disembodied like i just
wasn't in this vessel
and i've always been i guess kind of
like naturally on the thin
side so i could eat mcdonald's five to
seven times
a week in white castle and popeyes and
candy all day long and never exercise
and you know take birth control and it
just wasn't a thing i thought i was like
an irritable
tired person and that was kind of it you
know and when i was diagnosed with
something called hashimoto's thyroiditis
i just didn't want to take a
prescription for the rest of my life it
was really a matter of convenience
but i knew that there was no other way
you know that the conventional system
had to offer me and so
i went to a naturopath which is so funny
to me now because i was very disparaging
as you are
you know when you are dogmatic of
you know so-called alternative medicine
and
i went to this you know very brilliant
naturopath in new york city and she
helped me to adjust my diet
and i took a bunch of supplements and i
saw on paper which is what i needed the
way my mind works
i needed that proof i still do uh and i
saw on paper you know my antibody levels
you know go from the high 2000s to
normal range and my
something called tsh you know normalize
and
instead of feeling you know so excited
and wow i just you know put this into
remission
i was enraged something
ignited in me that was i'm still working
on
i'm still working on 11 years later and
i
i it's like i took my sword out of my
sheath and i was i ran naked onto
battlefield
and i spent years um
very angry you can even if if you've
read my first book
you can feel it you know i had a an
amazing co-writer who helped polish me
up a little bit but
you can feel it i felt the betrayal you
know that a child
feels when they see that their their
parent
you know injured them or harmed them or
maybe didn't have their best interest
at heart in a moment and
i i thought that very adolescent uh
fight for some
years against the pharmaceutical
industry as a whole
at the time i had also read a book
called anatomy of an epidemic
and uh by robert whittaker and who's an
intrepid investigative journalist
yeah and uh yeah you know him and uh
yeah
i never prescribed the medication again
after i turned the last page
i i committed uh it wasn't even an
effort actually
my entire practice for the ensuing you
know
11 some years to helping patients come
off of medication
and so i have you know more experience
than most the world over because i have
never restarted someone on medication i
have never initiated a medication since
that time
so i've come to really see what the dark
night of the soul
you know that is induced by these
medication withdrawal experiences and
and even very strategically engaged
tapers
uh what it can really look like on a
psycho-spiritual level but also on a
physiologic level
because i've said many times that i
believe
uh psychotropic medications to be the
most habit-forming chemicals on earth
and there's something very very powerful
as you know
um that is engaged when you when you
take that first
that first potion uh to your lips and
so you know since that time i've done a
lot of personal spiritual work
on transforming that rage and aggression
and anger and righteousness my shadow
really and i have spent probably the
past
three or so years but largely since
meeting my now husband
sayer um really trying to come into
you know that complementary energy that
feminine energy and
embody and really uh come into balance
as
you know a mother and uh someone who has
you know a heart to share as well i
guess
okay uh part of the reason i wanted to
have you on is because i've had
i it wasn't exactly a similar experience
but
when i found out that like when i put
myself into remission without the
medical
system like i'm still so angry about it
that it almost like
so i've been trying to work through that
and i'm not as angry as i was
like um i used to have panic attacks
going into hospitals i talked about this
on a previous episode but
it wasn't even something it wasn't
something i meant to do it's as soon as
i put myself into remission i i had
panic attacks going into hospitals and
my dad was like
that's a reasonable response given what
happened yes
yeah but still not super convenient
if i ever like break a bone and need
surgery um which is
you know you know might happen um but
yeah so i think we should talk a little
bit about
turning especially as a woman turning
that like anger
and rage and also ability
to be extremely competent in research
not to like toot my own horn or anything
but i mean
you're smart obviously you went to mit
then you figured out
that medical community isn't exactly
what everybody thinks it is which is
an insane discovery right and turning
that into some sort of
feminine spirit or power or something
i think we should touch on that a little
bit because mostly i just want to hear
what you have to say for me
but i'm sure somebody listening is also
going to take some lesson away from it
yeah i know it's you it's relevant it's
relevant to all of us right now
um in this current moment and i've come
to see
the sort of awareness generating
experiences that we sometimes bring to
ourselves like you mentioned being a
researcher right a citizen researcher
and i've come to see these
um you know sort of journeys as being
largely
driven by our relationship to our own
personal and specifically childhood
trauma
because i've come at it through the
intellectual
informational angle you know when i uh
started to research all pharmaceuticals
that i had ever
thought were sacred cows and that
includes the birth control i was taking
that includes all of the psychotropics i
was prescribing that includes
antibiotics of course i've taken plenty
of in my life
that includes vaccines which i was in a
position to have to decide around as a
new mother
uh i you know am very adept
at for whatever reason related to my
intellectual defense defenses i'm very
adept at
understanding reading and translating
scientific medical literature
and so i would collect all of these
references you know hundreds and
hundreds of them in my blogs and in my
books and whatever
and i would do presentations and
keynotes and all this stuff around the
world
and honestly i'm not sure i have ever
changed someone's mind that way yeah
ever not like literally not one person
ever and i'm a decent debater too you
know so i don't i'm not afraid
um you know to run my run my mouth and
that really stumped me because you know
when my first book came out which was
blacklisted
by mainstream media despite having
gotten a very uh generous
advance in being the feature book at
hartford collins in its you know publish
publishing season i thought well
anyone who reads this will never touch a
medication again
done case closed you know i've made the
point there's a better way
and obviously that did not happen which
is why i wrote a second book
largely about what it is that drives
our devotional trust
in a system that has never once
demonstrated that it has our
well-being in mind nor that it defines
health
in the same way that we do right most
most know that the conventional system
is terrified of death right this is an
existential issue that has been
codified into an entire system that is
now dominating
the world orthodoxy you know around this
concept of health being just the absence
of death
uh and that's not what we experience
health as right we experience health as
this very
complex dynamic uh vitalism right which
is more a chiropractor you know sort of
concept they've been championing that
for for decades
so i've really come to understand this
developmental maturational arc
that is the human journey
right that requires a very important
element which is
initiation to self and in our country
i'll just speak for americans
we have no relationship to that
whatsoever right we don't
know what it is to transition from
dependency on our parents
and our parents worldview and navigating
around that worldview
whether we reject it fiercely which is
what you're doing what i've done right
that rejection is is still
you know kind of circumnavigating the
authority of the parent
sovereignty doesn't look like that
adultification doesn't look like that
individuation doesn't look like that so
how do you transition
from either complying or defying with
your parents
or a projected authority whether that's
the medical system the doctor or the
teacher or the principal of the school
whatever it is your boss
how do you transition from you know that
dependent
patterning of relating to authority
through these vectors
into self-possession into an
understanding of
who you are and that your essential self
doesn't need anything else in the world
to change in order for you to be
okay right how do you access that spine
and still have your heart soft and open
that
normally is done indigenously
traditionally
through some sort of initiation ritual
that is held
by you know the community at large where
you're reflected
that when you think you're about to die
right so let's say it's a vision quest
or something like that
you don't you don't die and you come
into contact with that
deeper ground of being that will then
support you as you understand who it is
that you actually are
independent of those influences and
conditioning and programming
of your family of origin so this should
happen
in our teen years right but instead we
have this extended
childhood that takes us through college
where we you know
we don't have any understanding of who
it is that we are
and we are constantly following orders
encouraged to be obedient and compliant
and largely confined to a very very
small box
of critical thought right so my daughter
is 12 she's not in school she
has a very well paying job she runs a
business
natural business she's written a movie
script she's published poetry
and you know the list goes on and on and
on because
she can do all those things as a 12 year
old but culturally we have been
convinced that you have to wait till
you're like
26 to begin to start to do things you
know
on your own and this infantilization
is actually in my opinion because i'm an
arch conspiracy theorist you must know
is by design it's strategic to keep us
dependent
and in an experience of illusory
helplessness
out of touch with our own power so like
my advice would be you know
look at what's got the heat in your life
right like what can get your your heart
racing what can get you sweating what
can get you like
super angry you know
in 30 seconds and
you know for me that's like so many
aspects of the control grid the
government et cetera
medical system and recognize
that there is a projection happening
there
right of the bad daddy or the bad mommy
right and as long as you fight that bad
mommy you feel powerful
you hold the good and you project the
bad but
the true you know experience of our
power is in understanding the mix what
psychology is called a mixed object
right so this concept of you know i
we all have it all right so at the
beginning of this process in the past
year i took a long hard look
at the ways in which i might be
exhibiting the behaviors that i was
condemning
you know on the part of our ruling elite
and authority figures right so how and
where
is is kelly you know engaging in
totalitarian
you know dogmatic thinking how am i
living in hierarchical energy right so i
stepped down as ceo of my own
company uh actually at the end of
december
and i'm now in a partnership model with
my team which
to me was a gesture to the universe to
myself to them
of i am not the leader right i am not
the authority
we are all co-creating this together
because
i knew that otherwise i would be
consistently projecting those parts of
myself
onto more convenient entities to judge
than myself right so then i don't have
to look at how i am that
too right and whenever you hear so you
see someone pointing a finger
judging or whatever invariably they are
exhibiting exactly that which
they judge that's that's inevitable
right so how do we reclaim those aspects
of ourselves
we take radical responsibility
oh my cat's about to walk across the
computer sorry
we take radical responsibility
right because we are adults
and victim consciousness belongs in
the the child space right so
when we take radical responsibility we
own
our response no one
can hurt me but me no one
and that is not a popular concept and
that's why i've been
criticized for shaming victims and all
this stuff which is part of
of course the machinery of keeping
people victimized dependent
and helpless you know mental illness
destigmatization campaigns and
oh poor you with your depression take
your meds you know that's a
international agenda at this point and
it feels good for a moment
to be validated for our suffering
because we are suffering
right and and we are struggling and we
are confused and we are disconnected
but it's like this very you know
transitory
uh validation because ultimately what
you then need is a consistence called
often like narcissistic supply like
consistent
you know energy of validation of your
victimhood
all around you everyone's got to
acknowledge
how how hard it is for you how unfair it
is for you
right and we all do this we all do it we
complain and we have a complaining
culture
but when you take responsibility there's
no more blaming there's no more finger
pointing there's no more victimhood
everything fundamentally makes sense to
you
that is happening because it's through
the lens of your creative power
right so you come into a reclamation of
the fact that you've always had
this world creating power and you've
been told you don't
and you need these authorities to help
you safely navigate the dangerous random
world
you know that we live in and the truth
is
that we exp sorry it's like
very very intrusive today always
and the truth is that you know when we
shift even neurobiologically when we
shift out of helplessness and dependency
and
into self-possession all sorts of
so-called
miracles happen you know which is why
i've been able to publish
you know many many case reports case
series and even a randomized trial
demonstrating that you don't need a
doctor uh and you
yourself can heal in a short period of
time
from so-called chronic recidivistic and
even incurable
illnesses those miracles happen simply
because there is a shift a transfer of
the seat of power to the self from the
external
world and this can you know this can
happen
for any of us if we just start to take
responsibility for our daily choices
for our own self-care and for our
thought forms
that we are engaging and we start to
understand
dyadic dynamics and relationships that
we are in as
always mirroring you know that which we
might not otherwise want to look at
about ourselves
you know so because i believe that
victimhood and victim consciousness
is the only human pathology and once we
learn to transform that and step into
really an adult consciousness which is
far more complex and nuanced
and far more empowering then we we break
free it's like a spell
we're under we break free of so much
conditioning i mean nearly
instantaneously
that that was great i want that as the
clip
just putting that in there uh okay so
when i i had my i guess
transformation i don't know what to call
it because i'm pretty new to
this way of thinking but when i was
like 22 and i was so sick like i was
really dying my skin wasn't healing and
i was like i can't get help here
i can't get any help here i have to do
it myself
and then i did it myself and it took me
i'd been like pittering
pitter-pattering around in research for
the previous like four years but i went
like
all in and it took me eight months to
put myself into remission
from like joint replacement arthritis
and like bipolar and my skin not healing
it took me
eight months and i was like
what the hell is this and that's when it
was just like i saw
just like some sort of haze fell away
and i was just like horrified for
still but uh
yeah i i do like that that you take the
power out of the external world and then
it
starts growing in yourself or you find
it there
that's i mean yeah it's like a trope
right so i still have this like
atheistic
skeptical you know kind of like eye roll
to spirituality you know person in me
i'm still that person right
so like yeah yeah heal yourself do it
yourself no one can heal you like
there's still some part of me that's
like okay whatever
this sucks and how does it how do i keep
it from sucking right like whatever my
experience of illness is
but the the the shift is really around
fear right so are you afraid
of your own body if you're afraid of
your own body that your own body is
going to cause you pain suffering and
maybe even death
then you are living in this schism
right like you and your body are somehow
at war which is literally what we've
been conditioned around
think about even the semantics of our
medications
antibiotics which literally
etymologically means against
life okay antibiotics anti-hypertensives
antidepressants we are enculturated
around
warfare with the self because if we
fight ourselves of course it's a
losing battle an endless battle then we
will never recognize
who the true enemy of illusion is
right and so it's again it fits very
seamlessly
into a model that would keep us enslaved
and so the shift has to come from
understanding that symptoms are you
telling you about you
that's all they are they are
informational translation
some may say even you know from the soul
to the mind
to the awareness right and so if i have
a runny nose or pain in my elbow or
you know my hair starts falling out my
reflexive response
is curiosity it's not fear and that
fix it dominate it make it go away you
know sort of energy that we've been
uh reflexively conditioned around my
first response and so many
you know i'm sure yours at this point
too is what is this about
interesting right there's something that
i'm supposed to get from this
you know either i'm supposed to end my
relationship
or i'm supposed to change my breakfast
or maybe i'm supposed to look into that
smoke stack down the street you know or
that 5g tower or whatever
and there's something here that my body
is telling me is out of alignment the
body wants to heal
that's why in the space of a year you
can put
you know a devastating chronic illness
into full and lasting permission
you know i had the great privilege of
working with my mentor dr nicholas
gonzalez
for the last year of his life and he for
27 years
implemented a lifestyle protocol that
was primarily nutritional
to put terminal stage four
metastatic cancers in patients who are
otherwise
left for dead by the system literally
into not just
one or two or three or five years of
remission but
decades remission right
and i think that the fuel to the fire of
his practice
was his passionate belief that the body
does not
make mistakes and once you can connect
to that without
exception right so i don't even
conceptualize
like autoimmune illnesses as the body
attacking
itself right so the the immune system is
a whole we could have a whole
you know hour on that right like all the
lies we've been told about the immune
system
and what it is and it's these soldiers
fighting you know
this dangerous invisible demon enemies
whatever
the the language that we use is
important
right so if we say you know the body's
attacking itself or
you know an allergy is like a
misunderstanding of like
you know something benign or whatever we
still kind of get this
this relationship uh being born you know
to the body
that says oh silly body you're messing
up again
and if you can get to a place where you
understand
that without understanding the details
the body's
wisdom far surpasses your conscious
awareness
and that the invitation is to develop
that conscious awareness to learn
and you will you will it will become
clear
right to you what your body is trying to
tell you
which again can range from the
psychospiritual to
the very gross physical right so like
you're b12 deficient oh you know um
all the way to the fact that you know
you
you really need to start talking about
your childhood sexual abuse
you're going to know you know what this
is about and often it's multi-layered
right but you won't know unless your
your channel and connection to your
your intuition is intact
and in my experience that didn't even
begin
uh to come online until i cleared the
sleep right because if you have
brain fog and bloating and joint pain
and you're not sleeping and your
energy's in the tank whatever
the sort of like ritualized self-care of
looking at what you're eating
looking at what your you know or your
water is looking at your air
looking at your bedtime routine you know
looking at the very basics of all these
your products all these decisions you
have to make every single day
and beginning to bring the awareness
that you have many choices
and how do you want to deliberately make
a choice that is empowering you
right so you start to activate that
neurobiology of personal empowerment and
regeneration and shift out of fight or
flight
survival mode which we are invariably
going to be in
when we are living in the consciousness
of the dominant orthodoxy which says
everything is random protect yourself
best you can
take our help around how to stay safe
and do your best until you die right
try to stay afloat until you until you
drown right so of course we're going to
be in fight or flight
and so you you shift out of that through
simply looking at
the power of your choice in your
everyday decisions
and that's you know i've had a program
for many years that is simply predicated
on that
right how do i empower myself
clear the slate of my symptoms that are
just kind of trying to
pull on my skirt and say come on enough
already like take the wheel of your own
damn car
and begin to really start to get that
um that sense of connection to intuition
back online
because you know there's homeopathy
there's shamanism and plant medicine
you know there's essential oils there's
all types of you know trauma-related
um interventions there's so
many different healing modalities
available how do you know what's for you
it's so overwhelming yeah and then
you've got to take this one's word for
it and maybe read that blog but this
vlog says something different and
yeah that is not the way the way is to
understand how your body becomes an
instrument of your own decision making
right and and you will feel what a yes
feels like in your body you will feel
what a no feels like which is not what
you think right it's not the reactive no
of like oh hell no
no it's not like that it's a neutral
uncharged quiet
not for me that's not the way and this
yes no
in your body becomes available to you
when you start to
foreground your self-care you know when
i was in medical school i was taught as
is every conventional doctor that
nothing
in your environment matters right that's
the one
gene leads to one illness that requires
one pill or maybe ten
you know model nothing that you're
drinking or eating or thinking
you know or your partnership not it
doesn't matter it's like it's so
trite and silly to even worry about
those things they don't
matter so of course we think
yeah yeah of course it's nice to eat
healthy and maybe go for a jog once in a
while but
when you're sick you're sick right when
you have heart disease you have heart
disease
you've got to deal with that don't be
reckless and irresponsible imagine you
have to take
the appropriate medication for that so
to learn that not only do these things
matter but they are the only way to
actually resolve chronic illness which
conventional medicine has never
purported to do for one patient ever
in the history of medicine it doesn't
even claim that
it's not that's not on offer right so in
order to
access this concept of working with the
body to
come into greater alignment you know so
you're you're more vital
healthier you know and rejuvenated as
you age
you know than than when you were you
know 22 and didn't know what the hell
was going on
you must look at all of these choices
and you must start to decondition
you know that that brainwashing
i agree that's fantastic
okay why are you banned everywhere
my youtube is already demonetized so i
don't have any like
huge concerns about hosting people who
have been like de-platformed multiple
times
but what's the excuse like i put it up
on instagram if you look at your
wikipedia
the first sentence is i don't know
something about pseudoscience or
something
so like what have you been d platformed
off of and
are you given any reason and what are
you doing about it
yeah so it's kind of you know it's kind
of logical you know when
a mind of your own my first book um was
censored i remember
being on a call with the whole team at
harper collins and the publicist started
literally
crying because they had never
experienced this before
and you know i don't know that they've
ever
had a picture of an exploding pharma
pill on the cover of
a book written by an md before so that
might have been you know the novelty
there
but i knew that this was coming i knew
that i wasn't going to be
invited to the dr oz show or the today
show or 60 minutes and all the things
that they waltz their
you know kind of premier authors onto i
already knew that was going to happen
because these are 70 pharma subsidized
outlets
the illusion that media including
free media right so there's a
heavily circulated phrase at this point
right if it's free you're the product
the illusion that this is somehow
about information sharing as opposed to
mind control and manipulation of the
population
it just means you haven't researched you
don't know who somebody like edward
bernice is
you don't understand the concept of
propaganda and you certainly don't
understand the concept of funding
right and the tethering and capture and
control although it's about more than
money
of these entities by
you know whatever you want to call them
the elite the controllers you know
okay okay wait pause who would these
people be
this is where i get lost because i am
under the assumption that
people are like you when you went to
medical school
especially doctors they go in the
majority not all of them you get the
evil nurse that just likes to hurt
people from
from time to time but they go into
medical school and they're trying to
help people and then
they're taught certain things that are
wrong but
they're taught it in such a logical way
that it doesn't really make sense to
question it
and then they're just trying to help
people forever even though they're not
so who who would the people at the top
be
yeah i assume it's just stupidity no
it's intentional in my opinion and it's
malevolent
and actually you know um rudolph steiner
uh talks about
if you've heard of him uh philosopher
and
visionary and he created the waldorf
school program
and a branch of medicine called
anthroposophy that is
very similar it's kind of spiritual
medicine the way that i practice and
other things and you know he talks about
forms of evil
right and it's so different than we
might imagine right the caricature of
like the bad sadist you were saying
right
um and he talks about something called
luciferianism
right or luciferic energies and if i
describe it to you you're gonna be
pretty surprised because
as i was you'll recognize it in almost
every public
facing you know popular spiritual
guru out there right because this
concept
is that we need to transcend the body
we are all one and we are not separate
and when we transcend the body right
whether that's through
something like plant medicine or
meditation
then we come into contact with the real
self
with god and we are each god
right and so this energy of spirituality
doesn't care about the body
right and so if you you know if you
take a vaccine or you take a pill you
just
do a little meditation burn some sage
and say a mantra
it's good it's good you bless your meds
you know that kind of thinking
it's very prominent right now uh and
when we neglect the other pole
right which is the three-dimensional
materialism the fact that we actually
are incarnated in these bodies there
is cause and effect that's a thing right
then we're out of balance right and the
other arm is is the
reductionist concept that we're just
flush robots with gears and buttons and
you know we're prone to breaking down
and you know we're floating on a dead
rock in the middle of nowhere
until we die and this is very dominant
in the scientism sort of the public
facing scientism
uh consciousness that you know when i do
you know that psychiatrist
means doctor of the soul that's the
etymology of it right of course i
psych yeah yeah exactly right i've never
thought of that before
yeah i didn't until recently either and
and i
never heard the word soul if i had heard
it i would have rolled my eyes at it but
i never heard the word soul my entire
training not one time it wasn't about
that it was about managing chemicals
that's what a psychiatrist is they
manage chemicals right
and so when these two poles are out of
balance
very very dark energies you know
can manifest harm abuse
injury and all manner of disconnection
from you know what really is the truth
which is that we are embodied in a
sacred vessel
it's it's both yes we're in a body and
yes
it is a sacred temple and yes we are
divine
right it's both it's both those poles so
when you know
when you think about right because i
have you know friends of course and
um ex-husbands and because well just one
things like that
you know who are like oh come on like
yeah really
everyone is in the dark about this
agenda and they're all keeping a secret
that's really likely
no that's not how it works it's a
pyramid scheme
right so any any pyramid scheme whether
it's freemasonry or
you know multi-level marketing or
scientology or whatever
they have a few people at the top
who know what's up and who have a plan
that plan can relate to genocide
depopulation
uh you know it can relate to different
kinds of occultist religious beliefs
spiritual you know sort of orientation
whatever
they have a plan and nobody
beneath the tip of that you know
space pyramidal space knows what the
hell is going on
and that's by design right so as you get
lower and lower down the rungs and you
have people like me in medical school
just trying to be a good girl
right at the bottom implementing uh and
instituting
many of these um many elements of the
agenda
you know in disguise right so for
example in disguise
when you look at something like
circumcision or even
like the pap smear right or and modern
gynecology
when you look at you know medicalized
birth
there is so much occultist energy in
these things
let's just take a circumcision right
that is an occultist
and the implications of that not only
for
obviously that ritually abused child and
i participated in these as a medical
student
but also for the mother and for the
partner
are so legion and they reverberate
throughout our entire lives
that they can only be obfuscated and
obscured
by the assertion that it's medically
necessary so this is how and why they
turn
religious beliefs into you know
the secular objective you know sort of
realm of scientific beliefs they're
hiding it's all about illusion and games
that's why everything is actually
declared somewhere
right so you know you know the
rockefeller agenda for example
it's been written out since 2010. it's
on the internet
you can read what's going on exactly
what's happening now
you know event 201 from october of you
know a year
plus a go the videos are online
right they they it's part of the game
they want us to know
and they want us to experience the
cognitive dissonance that comes from
wait what is this about is this really
about what we're being told it's about
or is it about something else is there a
story behind the story
and then to suppress that
intuition that's a part of the machinery
of the game
is that we have to consent to
participating
in the illusion and suppress our own
intuition that it's something
different and that's you know
easy to do because we've all been
traumatized and we want to trust that
there is a protector that there is
someone safe that we can trust and there
is an authority figure
that would never you know the fda is
going to participate
in you know uh
the protection of serial felons also
known as you know pfizer johnson johnson
and astrazeneca
of course not that's ridiculous so many
people would have to be involved
right and so you go to nasa it's the
same story all of these entities
are riding on the the seat of doubt
you know that it could ever be possible
that this
large scale a deception could take root
and it does because we each choose to
trust
that these authorities have our best
interests at heart
and that such a thing could never happen
taxes
i mean it's the same story over and over
and over again in every single realm
education
uh and you know the rockefellers have a
lot to do with it
but they're not of course the only one
there some say they're like 13
influential families and bloodlines that
are contributing
some people have you know other
attributions you know to
other entities and yeah uh
you know other forces let's say i don't
know i don't think anybody really knows
but what you need to know is that you
have to source your own
information and you have to begin to
come into contact
with how it is that you identify your
truth and how it is that you turn over
every stone
because you know what if you go get uh
you know a test let's say to
to see whether or not you are virally
contaminated
do you have any idea what that test is
like do you know what it's testing
have you looked into it right and of
course no
is the answer for most people because
they say oh well i don't know how to
interpret science
the scientists figured it out and
obviously i'm
gonna just do what the scientists do
because i'm not an expert
but now we're being invited each of us
to access
our inner expertise because guess what
you are the only expert of you
no one no one no one no one on the
planet knows what's best for you
other than you defer to no one including
me
defer to no one and that doesn't mean
you can't kind of get a
sparked inspiration or interest to go
down a rabbit hole from someone
or confirmation or validation of your
intuition which is honestly all that
i've ever offered anyone since the
beginning of my career as an activist
is really like confirmation that they're
not crazy
right no you're actually not crazy and
you you are right you know
that there is a better way or nothing's
ever wrong with you or your meds we're
making you sick
right because we were trained in in
psychiatry
when patients would discontinue
medication which was normally like a
week and a half long process
uh and then of course they would get all
of these uh reap
sort of relapse symptoms yeah i've heard
right
exactly yeah you've heard that before
right and we were convinced uh
really convinced but also um coerced to
tell our patients that this is evidence
of their mental illness
and obviously justification for them to
restart the medication
you see you were a bad patient
and now you must be punished by going
back on your meds
forever you never get to stop them again
yeah and it wasn't until really 2014
that i started to see literature
mostly fava papa's group um published
that was asserting medically
scientifically that this has nothing to
do with relapse
that and it's not a so-called
discontinuation syndrome either
this is withdrawal and it's withdrawal
on the order of
opiates and of course in my opinion it's
actually far more extreme
as you know way more in my opinion way
more
i went through opiate withdrawal and
ssri withdrawal and
opiate withdrawal was bad for about six
weeks
and i could feel like the effects for a
couple of years after just cognitively
but ssri withdrawal made me hallucinate
and it took two and a half years to go
away
and i ended up on a zero carb diet
because i was
like hallucinating like not even
in the same magnitude and that was ssris
that wasn't even what my dad experienced
with benzodiazepines which was worse
like which was yeah that is the worst i
mean i remember when i was in
in training at bellevue in new york city
uh
i was working in the icu because as an
intern you know you kind of
rotate around different areas of the
hospital and i was looking at the icu
and i had a patient who has just
admitted
who had had a grand mal seizure in the
parking lot of
cvs going to fill his xanax
prescription and even then
i was not in a position to question
anything right and was very much a
believer
and even then i was like hmm
this doesn't seem right is this really
helping this dude
and of course now there are you know
millions of people the world over
you know your dad included who can tell
the story that there
are few challenges in life and i
actually think that the people who
are um somehow create the conditions to
experience psychotropic withdrawal are
very
special individuals right because to
move through those spaces
uh to move through those spaces is a
self-initiation
right so remember we were talking about
the dark night of the soul and all of
the elements of
of ego death uh that are involved in
that and surrender
you know to faith and trust um that
there's something in this life for you
that's more than what you can feel or
see in that in those moments of great
darkness
and we need those people who are
initiated to their power who are free
thinking
uh to help guide us now and i've said
you know many times that i believe
that those who are medicated uh
psychiatrically and diagnosed
are the canaries in the coal mine so
they are
rightly sensitive to what is wrong with
the world and they're being told
that something is wrong with them and
you know i often reference a
krishnamurti quote that says it's no
sign of health to be
well adapted to a profoundly sick
society right so if you have a panic
attack
when you go into a hospital yeah you
could say oh
wow something's really wrong with me
that's crazy why would i be so
hyper-reactive or as your dad said you
could say
that's totally appropriate you know
given um
you know where you've come from and of
course you can still get to a place
where that setting has no power over you
right yeah but that's a journey
that's a journey of self-reclamation and
it begins with appreciating
that your sensitivity and your so-called
symptoms and specifically
so-called psychiatric symptoms actually
come
from the seat of your perceptive power
which is your sensitivity right and if
we don't understand this or we don't
understand that it has to come with
personal responsibility
and resolution of victimhood those kind
of all have to come together
um or you will be operationalized and
leveraged by the system
empaths so-called empaths right these
sensitive folks
they are the foot soldiers of the
current agenda
though these are the people who say you
know
wear a mask for your grandmother right
because it's so intolerable to them
to to deal with this level of distress
or the the possibility that they could
be on the bad side the wrong side the
selfish
side of history that they become
you know the virtue signaling finger
waggers
because they haven't understood that
what comes with their sensitivity
is a fierce dedication to personal
responsibility
and resolution of victimhood right and
that's what i've seen you know with the
patients
um i've worked with and and some of them
including um
ali zak if you've heard of her work you
know who are on the public stage right
now
you know sounding the alarm uh have come
into their power
that was once labeled their mental
illness because of an understanding of
that personal responsibility and the
resolution of this
no fair it's not my fault it's your
fault
you know kind of energy i can totally
see why you're censored
i didn't know at least he was your
censor that was good that was great
i'm a bit more yeah of a controlled up
at this point on some level right
because
i i still have an instagram account even
though it's largely um i think there's
like five people who can see anything i
post yeah and you can't comment and you
can't swipe up or whatever it's funny
um i was the platformed off of facebook
and
the the truth is that they kind of
probably want to keep an eye
on me right and there are some like kind
of
you know trolls whatever you want to
call them
who are seemingly obsessed with me like
it's very adolescent energy
like constantly writing these extensive
blogs like studying my dynamics in my
marital relationship and
where i'm going in my dance videos and
it's just like wow
so much of their time you know is
devoted to thinking about me it's kind
of
amazing right because there's a lot of
um so-called astro turfing it's all
all bots right like it's all digitized
and there's no real humans it's just
generating the perception that there is
a
an organic movement against someone or
something or some concept but then
there's like actually some human beings
involved
who are you know working for the system
and whether or not they
you know know what they're doing who
will never know but i think it makes
total sense you know like
why should i be able to play in
facebook's sandbox according to my rules
of
of you know freedom well you could say
well we have constitutional entitlement
to free speech yes
and you know that would assume that the
constitution is what we think it is
and that it's being protected in the
ways that we think it is which i don't
actually believe so it's a it's a whole
another kind of bloodless war
you know that that we're at right now
and i think it's i think it's fine you
know this stuff doesn't get to me at all
for whatever reason i'm just kind of
wired this way to not
not care and to think it's kind of fun
and plus i believe in
bucky fuller's quote you know where you
don't fight the existing
system you know you create a new one
that renders it obsolete
and i know that we have to create a new
system and i know that we have to revoke
consent it's why i got off my smartphone
last year
because i know that my smartphone is my
first line of consent
to every aspect of the agenda maybe even
the transhumanistic
ai agenda that's being rolled out right
so if i
don't like that then how about i revoke
consent through my behavior
and i look at whether i want to actually
be buying on amazon and i look at
you know whether i have not that i have
stocks but other stocks and you know
certain companies that i'm actually then
publicly condemning and fighting so
becoming coherent
around our energy and effort is
something that we're actually being
invited towards so i don't
i don't actually think it's particularly
problematic although
my husband um does you know he spends a
lot of time
you know trying to um expose the
the unjust elements of you know what's
happening and the fact that we're being
targeted and sometimes even
you know threatened and and all the rest
but this has been going on for a long
time
for me you know i had aerial pictures of
my home uh when i was up north you know
with death threats because of a blog i
wrote on homebirth
imagine really i had a blog i wrote a
blog on home birth i
gave birth to my daughter at home
because i was like
[ __ ] no am i going into one of those
places
like you're gonna yeah no thank you
exactly horrible lights with a beeping
attached machines to you
and then no thank you but but you can
imagine right like if you empower women
to understand
that birth is their experience
of self-initiation it's their
entitlement and that they don't need
daddy medicine to manage their body for
them
all of the dangers when the body does it
wrong
and then to take the baby away and clean
that dirty baby
and vaccinate that you know broken
you know immune system and blah blah
blah all the rest
if it's like think about the ritual
uh power of that and when you get a mom
in that level of conditioning which of
course is amplified by all of the
emotions and all of that inner
pharmacopoeia of what's happening then
into the fold at that point you have her
for life
not just her her child right so that's
why home birth
is it's probably my number one advocacy
even though i focus
mostly on you know psychiatry but it's
the one that i feel
so passionately about because and i've
i've probably you know inspired i don't
know what
dozens of my friends because it's like i
will not shut up about this
i will not say oh i understand do the
best you can like no
this it happens one time per life you
know that you bring
forward and it is it is something that
every woman is capable of
and if we can only you know sort of uh
decondition ourselves and wake up in
time
because you don't get a do-over on that
right but of course i understand you
know why it garnered
that level of uh response because
remember i'm one of them
right i have that credential um
yeah you know and from a fancy place
carrier that's a lot just different it's
because people
are still enculturated to to listen to
somebody like me even though i'm saying
the same thing as
so many others you know uh including
non-clinicians and
and natural um clinicians and chinese
medicine practitioners all the rest
but because i'm from the priesthood you
know people are more willing to
to listen to me and that's potentially
why i'm more dangerous
and so you know the character
assassination is kind of the only way
they can get at uh calling me reckless
or dangerous or whatever
get at the undermining but honestly most
of the
criticisms that i've received they're
actually true
you know what i mean like no one's like
out there lying which i find interesting
because they could
for the most i mean i'm sure there are
exceptions but that's also been helpful
to me you know
because you know if if someone calls me
a co-leader for example
can i look at how i am a cult leader
right
i don't know maybe maybe there's
something in there you know so
it hasn't really had the desired effect
of intimidating me
shutting me up or otherwise
marginalizing me either you know because
my first book
made the the list of the hallowed
you know sort of um brotherhood itself
the new york times
right how weird is that after being
censored by all of these outlets that's
weird that's weird yeah that's
definitely it's like a wild game
okay that was fascinating
uh this is so fun i'm so glad you came
on i was a little bit worried because i
saw that you'd stopped using
a smartphone and i was like how how do i
get in touch with this human being
and get her on here i still have a
computer
yeah there are other ways there are
other better ways
yeah it's it's marginally better it's
actually been i prepared for like three
months i mean i wrote a whole like
ebook about it and everything else and
honestly it was so much easier than i
imagined i mean i was at a point where i
was feeling a lot of shame
actually uh as a mom you know being on
this device that i was telling my kids
not to be on
and not it's not like i was like messing
around on my phone like
on a dating app or something i was
working always working working
yeah trying to get rid of a couple
emails whatever and i'd be like kind of
hiding around the corner of the wall
you know like trying to get it done or
i'd be like always like
i can't remember the last time i went to
the bathroom without my smartphone or
did my laundry without my smartphone or
you know it's just
it was um i was like it's [ __ ] you know
and i went on a silent retreat actually
in march of last year and i came back
and i was like
you know i'm done i'm done i'm gonna at
least try
to regulate myself which never work and
try to do like the harm
you know sort of uh reduction model
of you know i only give myself a few
hours later or something like that yeah
yeah
that that didn't work and not only that
but then i stepped into the pandemic and
and started to research
18 hours a day or something for months
and months and months but yeah you know
confirming my intuition about what's
going on
and uh and then i just knew you know
that
it was time and it was so much easier so
much easier
than i thought i can't recommend it
enough i mean i have like a hipster flip
phone
now which is called a light phone and uh
i do my work on my computer so much more
efficiently and then i get up yeah and i
go live my damn life
you know so it's it is it does feel like
a reclamation and i feel
proud you know i feel proud of myself um
and i hope that you know others
others will consider and i know they
will because i started a telegram group
you know just to kind of learn a bit
about how to do this what about all
these apps and what do i do with this
and
in 12 hours there were 1600 people in
the group i have a one
well post on instagram seems like
something people are thinking about
right it's getting off these devices
yeah
and a lot of these apps that you use for
work or to communicate with other people
are
easy to put on your laptop whatsapp
telegram
signal like those are all on on your
laptop and
you type faster it makes sense i'm gonna
get there eventually because i have such
a work for you know like 18 hours like
just
constantly and then if i go i'll go lay
in the sun but i have my smartphone so
that i can be productive at the same
time as
getting some sun so uh yeah totally
it fits into that that um wound
right that like we have to always be
useful
um to always be accessible that was a
big one for me like if i don't respond
in time
i'm going to lose some of that value you
know to people and i'm going to lose
that aspect of my personality and
identity that is that kelly's
responsive and available you know
communicative
i don't know so whenever you know things
like this are scary it's because they
challenge
some of that illusory identity that
we've been writing you know that
that mask you know unintended that we've
been wearing that
it has to fall at some point right we
have to understand that
you know if if we are the person who's
always on time well we're also the
person who's
late sometimes right if we're the person
who's the intellectual well we also
say stupid things you know or like you
know how do we have both
how do we own it all and it's only
through not attaching to
any given identity uh with too much
rigidity
that we can try to understand like what
our essential core
is you know and what are the values of
that essential core i've become very
interested in
morals and values you know um as the
true guiding
principles and forces in in our lives
and
you know for me one of them is freedom
and that
is more important than any aspect of my
personality that i might have to shift
or change you know i used to hate cats
two years ago now
i have two cats and they're like deities
in my household i'm kind of comfortable
with that kind of thing you know like
being totally wrong
thought meds were good not so much okay
i think i think the only way to to heal
is to be okay with being wrong and i've
also found because i i was
i thought the medical system was there i
thought it had been helping me and
saving me and i was told i was broken
from the age of like
five or four before i can remember that
this is
you and you're broke and it's not your
fault and i think that's what made me
so angry that i when it was like oh wait
there's something i can do about this it
was like you took all my power away
by telling me that i was broken and that
there was nothing i could do about it
like how dare you and you're doing that
to other people
like how dare you take that power away
from people
so that's that's kind of where i'm
i'm operating for from i don't know
where i was going with that but i
have one more question for you that i
that i want to get to um
which is i like i've seen that you do
dance how old are you
this this wasn't the question but out of
curiosity i'm gonna be 43 and uh
okay so you look amazing you're
completely full of life
right so what are some like quick
suggestions you can give
people that that you've learned like
like i said i saw that you dance
like how much do you sleep like what
does your diet look like vaguely like
just yeah
easy things oh yeah i got a lot of these
um
and you know i'm a big believer in in
the
reset right my kind of reset um
not the great reset where you you
control for a lot of variables all at
once for something like a month
right so that's what my program has been
and i also recognize
that's like a barrier to entry for a lot
of people who don't want to take that
kind of a deep dive
and who just want to kind of like dip a
toe in or whatever and so that's what
we've done
uh sarah and i have a membership called
final life project where it's like
literally we
like for one week in a month everyone
goes to bed or who wants to
at 9pm that's a big one for me all right
because
i my entire life changed when i started
to go to bed early
and early is like i get ready for bed at
8 30.
and so if i'm meeting a girlfriend for
dinner or whatever
it's like a six o'clock reservation and
i'm in i live in miami
and i have most of my friends are um
latin
and you know from south america from
mexico or whatever
and the concept of eating a dinner at
six for them is like
that's like lunch right so i don't care
you want to hang out with me that's how
it is
so these sort of um priorities are
something that and then everybody gets
to know right like my kids know
i meditate every morning and they i've
been doing that for years and years now
so they just know they don't
bother me they wouldn't actually never
even imagine that they
could bother me like just don't go there
like she's doing her
thing and this is how you know so many
women who have
you know kids are still exercising that
that kind of narcissistic extension
psychology that we were raised with
which says you know i have to tend to my
child
so that my child you know reflects well
upon me and i can feel good about myself
right it's not the way the way is you
come first you come first
always without exception right in fact
i had an experience where um recently
where my youngest daughter
was having she's an empath for sure and
she was having this like inexplicable
anxiety right
and we in miami we have friends who run
an ecstatic dance
thing you know event uh every month
this is like it's church for me right
especially the daytime one on a sunday
and i missed it because i was
working with her right like on this
that's i think the only time
in 12 years of my mothering that i've
actually had that experience
of sacrificing like that
i just don't do it i put my needs
first and whether that's meditating in
the morning i move
probably six days a week and my
preferences
is dance and i wouldn't imagine
canceling that because of anything like
it's just not even a concept in my world
it comes first
and it comes first before work um and
and that
was a shift that happened recently for
me maybe three years ago when i moved
here so it's not like i've always been
this way
but my entire nervous system has changed
because of prioritize
prioritizing something that brings me
that kind of joy versus something that
feeds my defensive ego
that says i'm producing you know um and
helping or serving or whatever it is and
i am very very very strict
about certain aspects of my diet because
i heal myself as you know right like you
don't even want to mess around
necessarily and that's not to say i
don't have like intuitive flux
in my diet but i never ever ever consume
gmos gluten dairy or processed sugar
and i don't know that's just
so i if i go to a friend's house and
that's all they got i won't eat
and it's cool it's not like a big drama
you know it's just it's fine
um and i also am
extremely vigilant about conflicts in my
life
so wherever i feel that energy of
conflict
whether it's with a friend or you know a
family member
or a colleague um
that becomes foregrounded in my
consciousness as something i need to
address
and something i need to look into myself
to see how i'm contributing to it and
what kind of responsibility
i can take so that we can seek harmony
and
resolution because otherwise those
people hold elements of your power
through projection right condemnation
judgment
and i need all of my all of my power
here centralized um you know but i
i have been in the past couple of years
since moving to miami from new york
really
in a process of orienting you know
around a different set of priorities and
new york is very
um as most people know um very much
feeds that
masculine impulse you know towards uh
productivity and um
really a kind of relationship to time uh
as something you know to kind of like
it's like a scarcity mentality i guess
versus an abundant mentality that says
like
i'm here now you know where do i gotta
be you know i don't have to be anywhere
you know that which is so much more the
culture down here was shocking to me
when i moved here it took like six
months for me to
adjust you know to people don't use
email they don't show up
they show up hour late you know or it's
just a whole different
uh culture which actually was very
healing for me in resolving
um rigidity but i would say anybody who
wants to
take a step towards this process
uh change your breakfast that's that's
normally what i
i suggest you know change your breakfast
so that
at least it's you know free of those
things i mentioned
gluten dairy sugar gmo free and see what
happens
right because even that little teeny
teeny commitment
begins to disrupt the belief system
that none of it matters and that this is
kind of how it's going to be for you
and all it is is a choice you know in my
in my protocol if i don't mind reset
there's no supplements at all why not
because supplements are not wonderful
all right i'm sure they are and have
helped many many people
uh in fact sayer's entire database you
know greenman info
indexes tens of thousands of primary
uh literature studies that suggest that
they're actually
more helpful you know than medications
however
there is an experience of i need this
because something in me is missing
that i think it's very psychologically
important to disrupt
and so when we just look at the choices
that we make every day
sleep eating contemplation you know the
products do i buy this detergent or that
detergent
then you begin to see i'm the one
driving the car
oh okay i thought it was the passenger
interesting
and that has a cascade of effects that
also i think correlates to
um like i said in your own biology that
affords us the capacity to regenerate
and to heal
from things that we've been told we
might suffer from
for life
that was epic thank you so much for
coming on
um if people are trying to find you or
want to find your books
what are they called and where can they
find you
cool so i am at kellybroganmd.com and
there's a ton
ton of free information there i've been
blogging highly referenced blogs for
many years now
um and the
uh best way to stay in touch with me is
through my newsletter because who knows
right now i'm on telegram uh i have a
telegram channel
and so far so good but who knows right
it's like i call it the census
censorship shuffle like we don't know we
gotta be nimble
uh so that's why the newsletter is the
better the better bet
and yeah mind of your own own yourself
and then i have a kids book that i wrote
with my daughter
called a time for rain that i'm really
proud of actually
and those are all at the moment
uh at barnes noble and amazon
thank you very much for coming on that
was that was fascinating
it's a total pleasure
[Music]
you